what is your pre-game ritual I usually
sleep in late so I don't have much more
time than to eat try to eat twice look
at my preparation maybe go for a short
walk and that's it maybe or maybe I'll
go to the gym I'll probably definitely
listen to some music though and
definitely take a nap before the game
since it's a much later start yeah I
like to sleep yeah after lunch I prefer
to have a rest before the game made my
mind clear first I have an app and then
I listen to something that helps me
happen and I go to the game so that's my
little ritual I believe we keep like the
same routine which doesn't involve any
Supernatural stuff I like to brush my
teeth
seems to be quite practical and I think
dressing calms me down as well everyone
wants to sleep wants to eat wants to
prepare a little BTA and you know the
only task is to combine it correctly yes
I'm not sure we're sleep not to
overeating not to over prepare for sure